I want to show you a cartoonish video of
a trump official talking out of both
sides of his mouth and then I want to
have a serious conversation and actually
trying to talk about facts this is video
of Donald from Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo he went or Pompeo at some column
he went on ABC's this week over the
weekend with Martha Raddatz and during
30 seconds this is 30 seconds he said
yes coronavirus was man-made
no coronavirus was not man-made this is
the same guy this is the same day this
is the same interview this is the same
32 second segment completely incoherent
take a look at this it was man-made or
genetically modified but the best
experts so far seem to think it was
man-made have no reason to disbelieve
that at this point your your office of
the DNI says the consensus the
scientific consensus was not man-made or
genetically modified that's right I I
agree with that
yeah I've say I've seen their analysis
I've seen the summary that you saw that
was released publicly I have no reason
to doubt that that is accurate now I
have no reason to disbelieve it was
man-made and my office is correct that
it's not man-made that is direct
conflict okay you if you haven't been
following this Donald Trump and others
have been talking about whether
coronavirus instead of simply coming
from bats jumping to humans and then
spreading if it might have been a
project of a level 4 biosafety
laboratory in Wuhan China and could have
escaped because of a mistake or maybe it
was even released deliberately like a
bio weapon now there are some fringe
conspiracy theories that insist that it
was a deliberately released man-made bio
weapon that's I mean I'm not even going
to take that seriously because there's
no evidence of that there have been some
reports that have jumped to relatively
mainstream corporate media which say
it's being looked at not whether it was
man-made
but whether it was naturally occurring
but was being studied in the lab
through an accident came out of the lab
okay now I just want to make sure we're
clear on the possibilities we're talking
about and the ones that we are not so
the possibilities are this came from
bats and was transmitted in public
through natural means it came from bats
was being studied in this lab and was
accidentally released it came from bats
was studied in the lab and was
deliberately released it was completely
man-made but released accidentally and
then of course it was completely
man-made and released on purpose as a
bio weapon I'm only talking about
scenarios 1 & 2 which is if this was
being studied at this lab it was
released as an accident due to a mistake
the reason we are even having this
conversation is because there actually
have been some reports saying that this
is being looked at countless scientific
sources have already identified that it
is of natural origin that wouldn't
preclude it from having been studied at
this wuhan lab and that's the reason
that we're bringing it out now what is a
biosafety level 4 lab anyway what we're
talking about is the Wuhan Institute of
virology this has been around since 2015
biosafety level 4 is when you were
working with easily transmitted
transmissible pathogens which can often
be transmitted via aerosol and which can
cause human death if a human is infected
often there would be no treatment or
vaccination if a human were to be
infected that's the level lab that they
have in Wuhan and there's a whole bunch
of other technical requirements if you
are level 4 so my position is before we
know for sure at this point it appears
that this is a naturally occurring
corona virus that came originally from
bats transmitted in public I'm open to
the idea that it may have been a
pathogen being researched in this lab if
we have evidence of that then we'll take
it more seriously as of right now I
don't believe that that was the case I
don't believe it was a bio weapon or
released on purpose but here's the
serious thing to consider ok if this was
something being researched in this
corona in this a Wuhan lab
in China and it was released
accidentally it changes nothing of
Donald Trump's response to the
coronavirus if it was completely
naturally transmitted the United States
in South Korea had their first cases
within hours of each other
South Korea handled it properly and the
United States did not
South Korea's death rate is five people
per million the u.s. death rate is 210
people per million
you didn't miss hear that our death rate
per population is 42 times that of South
Korea's so if this was mishandled at the
Wuhan lab and accidentally released that
must be researched that must be dealt
with and within China there are already
fears of a backlash like the ones seen
because of the Tiananmen Square incident
we'll talk about that on the bonus show
if that's the case there will be
backlash we all know that but it doesn't
make a difference in terms of evaluating
Trump's handling if it spread at a Wuhan
wet market Trump's response was terrible
if it came accidentally being released
from a Wuhan level for biosafety lab
Trump's response was still terrible it's
a very important thing that we not allow
the story about the source to distract
from our federal government's failed
response and from Donald Trump's
constant lies and attacks and smears as
a result of the virus will follow the
story we'll take it where it leads us it
does nothing to make Donald Trump's
response anything but completely abysmal
privacy calm is one of our sponsors and
they're giving you $5.00 just for using
their free service at privacy calm slash
Pakman privacy's of service I've been
using for a while now I love it it saves
me a bunch of headaches it's completely
free and it's very quick to set up and
here's how it works when you pay for
something online or over the phone
instead of exposing your real credit
card number privacy lets you generate
virtual card numbers the payments are
withdrawn from your checking account but
your real card number stays completely
private and you do it all with one click
you can auto
fill the card number in your web browser
on the phone you can create 12 virtual
cards a month you can set spending
limits freeze them delete them whenever
you want I especially love it for free
trials where you need to give a credit
card number because I can destroy the
virtual card number as soon as I give it
to the company and I know I won't be
charged in the future if you're ordering
food over the phone why do I need to
give a restaurant my real card number I
don't have to companies don't have to
know who you are your real credit card
number is protected from the data
breaches that happen unfortunately more
often than we would like and it's
completely free they do have a paid
version with different tiers where you
can create more virtual credit card
numbers per month cash back rewards
extra security features but go ahead and
sign up for the free service it's a no
brainer companies can't charge you
unexpectedly you're protected from
identity theft it costs you nothing and
privacy is giving you five dollars to
spend just for signing up when you go to
privacy calm slash Pakman